it's a problem that they're collecting
data but my bigger concern is the
algorithmic manipulation and what
they're so like we've talked about if
you look at Dylan Mulvaney's Tick Tock
early on Dylan was doing Animals nature
and that content did not work and trans
weren't when when first non-binary and
it did a little bump then trans
Skyrocket because Tick Tock said promote
this
so what's happening is you enter a
platform where this is what Alex was
talking about uh Stein when he said I
mentioned 49 censorship 51 speech they
allow 51 of the ideas they want to pass
to be allowed and they censor 14 uh they
own they allow Among Us 49 of our
conversations and among the left 51 over
a long enough period of time they're
creating a a pressure system that pushes
people to the left it also is a
exponential algorithm because right 51
tomorrow is gonna be like 51.7 the next
day it compounds so so that's my bigger
concern with tick tock